[Music]
Rutherford's gold foil experiment give
him interesting results what results did
he get by the way let me recall them for
you
he found that most of the fast-moving
alpha particles passed straight through
the foil and hit the detector
however some particles got deflected by
small angles and lastly to his
astonishment few alpha particles also
rebounded now how can this be possible
these three observations made Rutherford
think that the plum pudding model is not
really correct let us take a simplified
example to understand the inferences
first let us imagine that we have a ball
made up of cotton the cotton in the ball
is very sparsely distributed and has an
extremely tiny circle or sphere located
at the center this sphere is quite hard
and dense so hard that it can even
resist a bullet shot against it now what
will happen if you shoot many bullets
across this cotton ball most of them
will travel straight through the cotton
surface what will happen if a bullet
hits the edge of the central heavy mass
in this case the bullet will slightly
change their path and get deviated so
looking at the size of the central mass
it's obvious that only some of the
bullets will get deviated lastly what
happens when a bullet hits the center
directly needless to say it will bounce
back because we know that the central
dense mass is too hard for the bullet to
pass through so very few bullets will
bounce back this is analogous to what
Rutherford had inferred about the atomic
structure his first conclusion was that
most of the space inside an atom is
empty this is because most of the alpha
particles could easily pass through the
atoms and hit the detector straight now
if most of the space is empty inside an
atom then where is the positive charge
located well that's the second
conclusion the positive charge is
compactly packed in a tiny entity this
occupies
extremely small space inside the Atem
now why did he think so let's go back to
a cotton ball and bullet example can you
recall the second in the third case yes
the bullets get deviated on hitting the
tiny sphere of the edge and they will
rebound when they hit the center same
explanation holds true for this a few
alpha particles get deviated that means
there is a possibility that these hit
the edge of the positive Center yes and
one more possibility is that they get
deviated because the positive Center
repels the alpha particles as they're
also positively charged also a very
small number of alpha particles
rebounded that means there is a
possibility that these are four
particles had directly hit the positive
Center but since the number of these
rebounding particles is too small it
explains that the volume occupied by the
positive Center is also very small if
the space occupied would have been big
enough then the number of alpha
particles bouncing back would also be
greater so let's say there are gold
particles in the foil he found that most
of the rays passed straight through the
atoms a few rays changed their path and
get deflected
lastly very few particles bounce back
these results compels Rutherford to come
up with a new nuclear model let's have a
look at the hypothesis put forward by
him firstly there's the positively
charged Center in an atom called nucleus
nearly all the mass of an atom resides
in the nucleus secondly the electrons
revolve around the nucleus in circular
paths thirdly the size of the nucleus is
very small compared to the size of an
atom
however theoretically there were many
flaws in the hypothesis let's have a
look at the drawbacks in Rutherford's
hypotheses in the next video also we
will have a look at the explanation of
atomic structure by another scientist
named Niels Bohr in the next video
[Music]
you